the upcoming onyx logic program will be
focused on transcriptomics we will have
almost three months to discuss the
various aspects of RNA seek data
analysis and how this field of
bioinformatics continues to evolve the
year 2020 marks a 70 year mark since the
discovery of the structure and function
of the DNA molecule at 2015 the 1000
genome project brought a significant
number of whole genome sequences to the
research community and in 2018 over
100,000 whole genomes were sequenced
today there is an ever increasing number
of genomic transcriptomics proteomics
and made of genomic data sets available
that describe subcellular processes with
highly detailed digital data in this
program we will focus on one type of
this data transcriptomics this program
will cover analysis of gene expression
data with practical sessions and online
tutorials anyone with a basic knowledge
of cell and molecular biology will be
able to conceptually understand as well
as practically apply standard data
analysis tools to process analyze and
interpret complex transcriptomic data we
will do so by leveraging regular online
webinars practical exercises and online
courses in addition to online courses
all participants will get access to
hands-on exercises and data sets for
practice these can be completed without
any coding using the analytical t-- bio
info platform that provides an
interactive learning experience the
platform is color coded to help
establish a logical connection between
theoretical aspects of data analysis
methods and the practical steps needed
to achieve a biologically interpretable
result a major topic of analysis of
transcriptomic data is identification of
differentially expressed genes and
isoforms the online session will
supplement information offered in
transcriptomics to module that describes
a number of statistical techniques
typically used for simple and more
complex approaches to finding
differentially expressed genes
exploring data and understanding its
statistical properties can help a spot
technical variation that can have
unwanted effects on our analysis some of
the techniques are easy to use and can
be done in Excel or any other type of
table manipulation software others
require a more streamlined approach many
of these are available on the analytical
platform we will use once the data is
standardized and prepared we will learn
about working the identified genes to
arrive at a biological interpretation of
our results oftentimes standard
statistical tests do not capture the
granularity of expression data in a
given data set to learn about methods
that can handle complexity that is
typical for large onyx datasets we have
to learn about additional methods of
dimensionality reduction data mining and
classification for example PCA can help
us understand variability between
samples by analyzing all of our data
features we can use such dimensionality
reduction techniques to get a better
insight of our data set and visualize it
as a result we can study genes how they
describe samples in our data set and how
this correlates with phenotypic
information we have for biological or
even clinical interpretation mastering
these methods will help you understand
biomarker discovery and patient
stratification both of which use
predictive modeling and feature
selection finally we will conclude the
program speaking about single-celled
transcriptomics single-celled
transcriptomics helps identify all
messenger RNA is present in a single
cell unlike bulk RNA seek profiling or
sequencing libraries are generated from
thousands of cells SC RNA see
technologies isolate single cells and
generate cell specific sequencing
libraries each participant will have an
opportunity to study these techniques in
the context of a project we prepared a
number of various examples you can pick
from ranging from biomedical to agro
biological studies many of our past
participants had a chance to present
their analysis in front of their
classmates or even conference poster
sessions and workshops
the materials we collected have been
reviewed by faculty and students from
top US and international universities
this kind of feedback demonstrates that
the learning will be effective and even
transformational